[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Catherine a Renou
vice-présidente des Yvelines délégués à
l'insertion à la rénovation urbaine on
va parler ensemble du dispositif
prieur-yvelines bonjour bonjour alors en
décembre 2022 le département a prouvé la
création du programme prioriveling 2023
2027 un programme qui ne date pas d'hier
puisqu'il a été approuvé pour la
première fois en 2015 alors quels sont
les ambitions et les objectifs de ce
dispositif alors vous l'avez bien dit
c'est la deuxième partie d'un prior qui
avait déjà été très ambitieux et qui
avait deux volets on le retrouve dans le
prieur numéro 2 le premier volet c'était
l'accompagnement de la résidentielle
c'est-à-dire accompagnement de la
construction de logements dans les
communes qui souhaitent et déficiter en
logements social soit vers la volonté
parce qu'elles en avaient pris
l'engagement de construire des logements
essentiellement pour des classes
moyennes et le deuxième volet qui était
lui très innovant c'était le volet
rénovation urbaine c'est-à-dire
l'accompagnement sur les territoires dit
en quartiers politiques de la ville de
rénovation urbaine c'est assez
ambitieuse là où l'État était ou n'était
pas c'est-à-dire là où l'on rue
financait et même dans dans un certain
nombre de situation une finance pas le
prix numéro 2 à cette même ambition
en allant un peu plus loin bien
évidemment bien évidemment accompagner
les collectivités à la fois lorsqu'elles
ont l'ambition la volonté de construire
du logement et du logement de qualité et
accessible à un plus grand nombre avec
du logement donc en propriété c'est
l'occasion pour le département soit
d'équilibrer le déficit financier de des
opérations lourdes soit d'accompagner la
collectivité dans l'offre de services
publics elle peut faire pour ses
nouveaux habitants service public petit
enfant service public école voilà
aménagement pour les nouveaux habitants
et le deuxième c'est toujours le même
volet qui est encore plus original
puisque c'est le volet rénovation
urbaine mais sur des quartiers qui n'ont
pas du tout été ciblés jusqu'à présent
par l'État comme quartier en difficulté
mais que nous nous avons senti ou
signifier comme fragile et de façon à ce
que on n'arrive pas dans des quartiers
de grandes perdition comme ça a été le
cas que le département puisse
accompagner les villes à intervenir
avant alors justement comment est-ce que
vous avez ciblé ces quartiers que vous
estimez prioritaire dans cette
rénovation dans ce dispositif prior
Yvelines alors sur ces sur la rénovation
urbaine prior innovation urbaine en fait
on a un certain nombre de critères qui
sont connus les critères de fragilité
des critères des critères d'emploi ou
d'accession à l'emploi des crédits de
fragilité
des jeunes entre les jeunes non
scolarisés au-delà de 16 ans voilà tout
un tas et puis des quartiers de et puis
des fragilités de bâti parce qu'il y a
quelque fois il y a les fragilités des
habitants mais il y a aussi la fragilité
d'un bâti d'un bâtir ancien d'un bâti de
logements social n'ayant jamais été
rénové et sur lequel on ne peut pas
laisser comme ça se dégrader donc il y a
neuf villes qui ont été ciblées en plus
de celle qui existait déjà qui n'était
pas dans les radars de la rénovation
urbaine de l'État mais sur lesquels nous
voulons accompagner les maires s'ils ont
l'ambition de porter une rénovation
urbaine alors justement donc
priori-velin 2015 un pour pour la
première date il se poursuit donc
notamment jusqu'en 2027 est-ce que au
moment de sa création en 2005 il y avait
en 2015 pardon il y avait une demande
d'aide importante de la part des
communes des Yvelines et même des
yvelinois alors les Yvelinois ne
connaissent pas toujours l'importance
d'un département et de l'accompagnement
du département au collectivités locales
certaines collectivités oui étaient
demandeuses mais de toute évidence des
plans et des contrats départementaux
sous toutes formes il n'y a tout il y en
a toujours un Yvelines comme ailleurs en
2015 et en 2016 on a eu l'ambition de
travailler une politique contractuelle
très très différentes qui n'était pas
qui n'étaient pas limité ni dans le ni
dans les financements ni dans les
pourcentages mais qui avait comme
ambition d'accompagner d'une façon très
volontariste les collectivités qui est
les bailleurs sociaux qui avaient la
volonté de vraiment se lancer dans une
rénovation urbaine donc c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé ça se passera de la
même façon cette fois-ci c'est à dire
pas de limite financière je dis pas de
limite il y en a toujours mais pas de
limite d'objectif pas de limite de
pourcentage le département doit investir
là où il est vraiment l'élément
déclencheur de cette ambition et de
cette réussite le département général
investit toujours dans le dans le
bien-être en tout cas pour les Yvelinois
on est encore dans une logique justement
d'investissement pour les Yvelinois pour
des meilleurs logements et pour des
logements moins chers finalement et oui
vous savez combien il y a une demande de
logement donne dans notre département
qui est très important mais on peut pas
laisser construire n'importe quoi et
n'importe où c'est l'avantage de cette
politique départementale cette politique
d'accompagnement financier au bailleur
sociaux au bailleur et aux collectivités
c'est d'accompagner de la grande qualité
dans les lieux choisis là où le besoin
se fait sentir où il était correctement
étudié et de façon à accompagner une
qualité de vie pour ces nouveaux
Yvelines qui soient à la hauteur de ce
qu'on espère alors justement comment
est-ce que les collectivités doivent ou
peuvent faire comme comme démarche pour
demander justement une subvention au
département et ce qu'il y a finalement
un contrat aussi de de respect
finalement notamment pour des logements
de de respect d'une norme etc pour voilà
accueillir de nouveaux yvelinois ou de
futurs Yvelines
c'est que c'est une espèce d'appel à
manifestation c'est à dire que les
villes selon que c'est un programme
rénovation urbaine ou un programme
résidentiel ont jusqu'à soit fin 2023
soit fin 2025 pour se porter candidate
mais au-delà de se porter candidate il
faut qu'elles aient fait elles-mêmes des
études et qu'elles amènent une ébauche
de projet montrant en tout cas les
difficultés leur territoire les besoins
de rapidement du département il y a il y
a une grande qualité environnementale
demandée mais il n'y a pas une
labellisation c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment comme le maximum de ce qu'on
puisse faire en qualité d'habitat en
cavité environnementale selon l'endroit
où on se trouve et les conditions mais
de toute façon c'était une vision que
nous avions déjà dans le mandat
précédent une grande qualité
environnementale de l'habitat de qualité
de l'habitat qui dure pour le meilleur
accueil du nouveau yvelinois alors quand
on parle des Yvelines pardon et plus
largement de l'Île-de-France on pense
tout de suite que les logements sont
hors de prix c'est une idée que le
département en tout cas des Yvelines
souhaite déconstruire notamment à
travers prior Evelyne c'est une
accessibilité plus simple aux jeunes
ménages par exemple et au ménages avec
un revenu moyen absolument c'est c'est
cette cette tranche de la population qui
cherche désespérément adeco habités mais
à rester à proximité de ce qu'ils ont
souvent vécu dans dans leur enfance en
fait c'est une population qui a besoin
de
appris maîtriser et c'est pour ça que
l'intervention du département est
extrêmement importante si on laisse tout
filer effectivement il y a des
territoires où les prix seront
inabordables pour nos classes moyennes
en accompagnement un équilibre financier
des opérations le département prend
l'engagement de pouvoir accéder à la
propriété pour ces cette classe moyenne
qui le réclame alors vous en tant que
justement vice-présidente donc délégué à
l'insertion et à la rénovation urbaine
quelles sont vos priorités justement
pour l'année 2023 et est-ce que
priorivelyne votre objectif c'est
justement de l'étendre encore après 2027
alors de toute façon les programmes de
rénovation urbaine sont extrêmement
longs ils sont toujours beaucoup plus
longs que l'écart d’année que nous avons
prévues c'est le cas du premier prior
qui est loin d'être fini qui rentre un
peu en dans le dur d'ailleurs alors ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut dans cette
année 2023 c'est accompagné toutes les
collectivités tous les maires qui sont
volontaires pour justement
refaire du nouveau et de la qualité de
vie dans leur quartier prioritaire donc
là c'est c'est l'année où on va
accompagner ces mères pour lancer à la
fois les études et puis et puis de faire
des propositions se porter candidat
d'une part c'est aussi ces programmes de
rénovation urbaine numéro 1 qui avait
commencé en 2015 vous savez c'est
extrêmement long donc chacun rentre
actuellement dans le dans ce qui est
vice du skate visible par l'habitant et
puis ne pas oublier que il y a des il y
a les habitants qui cherchent à
abidariser il y a ceux qui habitent et
ce qui habitent il y a une grande partie
de notre population qui est bénéficiaire
du RSA et c'est ma deuxième casquette et
c'est aussi accompagné
bénéficiaires du RSA vers plus d'emplois
s'il y a une reprise du bâtiment il y a
un certain nombre d'emplois qui sont mis
sur le marché c'est le cas depuis
environ 6 mois il faut vraiment
accompagner les bénéficiaires du RSA
pour à la fois se former devenir
employable et aller vers un emploi
durable alors l'état est également enfin
intervient en tant que en tant que
aidant pour justement c'est logement
c'est rénovations urbaines etc est-ce
que cette réponse c'est justement l'État
ne fait pas parfois suffisamment ou n'a
pas suffisamment de de comment dire de
de de réponse à fournir à ces personnes
là qui ont du mal à se loger en tout cas
le département des Yvelines s'estime qui
qui peut réagir seul face à ces petits
problèmes des communes des collectivités
face au logement alors l'État intervient
sur un certain nombre de choses mais la
rénovation urbaine par exemple même si
c'était une politique nationale assez
volontariste il faut savoir que dans les
Yvelines pour 1 euro investi par l'État
2 euros sont avertis par le Département
c'est à dire que l'investissement de
l'État n'était jamais suffisant dans
l'accompagnement de la construction de
rénovation énergétique l'état donne
quelques moyens mais ils ne sont pas
suffisants pour changer fondamentalement
l'avenir du logement sur notre
territoire il faut une politique forte
très très ambitieuse et je le redis
beaucoup parce que c'est pendant ces
deux mandats là il faut qu'elle soit
suffisamment ambitieuse pour qu'on ait
accompagné et qu'on ait créé
suffisamment de logements pour les
années à venir et on peut retrouver plus
d'informations donc sur l'actualité des
Yvelines et notamment sur le dispositif
prioribling sur le site yvelines.fr
merci beaucoup Catherine arenou d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]